when Samsung announced the s24 ultra I
thought that it was one of the most
boring updates ever but now that I've
used it for about a week I have to say
that I was wrong and being a big iPhone
fan I want to share with you guys why I
think that this phone is better than the
15 Pro Max after using it now I need to
start off with the design Samsung copied
Apple in many ways first we have tit
tianium and honestly I don't think it
makes a big difference at all you can't
really tell because it didn't do much
for the phone compared to the s23 ultra
whereas with the iPhone these things got
a lot lighter now surprisingly what does
make a huge difference is that the glass
is now flat for many years Samsung
embraced these crazy curves and they
slowly tapered it back but holding the
s23 and the s24 that the s24 feels much
more modern it looks clean with super
thin even bezels all around and it makes
the display look much bigger than my
iPhones now with that said that is not
the only difference in the display what
shocked me and everybody else at maxtech
is how little Reflections you have in
the screen Apple had great screens and
the best antireflectivity for years but
this s24 Ultra makes the Iphone look bad
not only because the blacks look super
dark and pure black but also because now
the screen is ultra bright Now Android
manufacturers quote super high knit
ratings all the time and for years the
Samsungs weren't actually brighter in
most used cases but now even in manual
mode if you Max it out the screen is
brighter same thing for outdoors it's a
notice noticeble difference and
especially with the antireflectivity
this screen has just amazed me each time
that I pick up the phone it kind of
reminds me when I bought my first
Samsung the original Galaxy with the Ola
display and this is actually the first
time since then where a display really
really surprises me and I think that is
a massive difference for anybody with an
older Samsung now I love that the whole
punch is Tiny compared to my iPhone it
makes watching videos so much nicer now
Samsung also managed to make this phone
thinner than the previous ones while
packing in a bigger punch which is
surprising and because of that you don't
really want to get a case that is super
thick and bulky and you guys probably
notice I have the Paka mag easy case 4
on here it is extremely thin very
lightweight you practically don't notice
it while adding extra protection it's
made from aramid fiber and that makes it
more t tactile and grippy and this right
here is the sunset color but you also
have the choice of your standard black
and gray design which is really nice now
probably my biggest disappointment with
the s24 ultra is that Samsung did not
put in wireless charging magnet but this
case actually has mag safe built right
in so you can get that perfect alignment
and no it does not interfere with your S
Pen when you're using the case as long
as you're not stacking a bunch of other
accessories Paka also has some screen
protectors so if you're looking for an
ultra thin really nice case I'll go a
and Link them down below now the next
thing that really surprised me is the
performance of course we have the
Snapdragon 8 gen 3 inside of here and I
was shocked to see how close the CPU
performance was to the iPhone and with
that in daily use all apps launch super
quick just as fast fast as on the iPhone
the multitasking is great super smooth
at scrolling I mean there's no issues
I've had issues with Samsung's before
where you'd have a little glitchiness
slowdowns but this thing is incredibly
fast and then when it comes to gaming
performance it is embarrassing the
Apple's 3 nanometer A7 Pro gets smoked
and destroyed by the 4 nanometer
Qualcomm chip and with that the actual
gaming experience was also excellent I
maxed out all of the settings I played
for a while and the phone didn't even
get warm the thermal design in here is
great unlike Apple which doesn't do
anything at all and it gets really hot
it starts to slow down this thing is
incredible at gaming and of course we
also have the S Pen and all of the AI
stuff that Samsung really talked about
that the Spen is great I typically play
around with it for a little bit but I
can never get into a daily habit of
using it even when I was consistently
using Samsung phones a while back but as
far as AI I think the coolest real world
thing for me was being able to just
delete stuff out of photos this works
super fast it works well and it's
something that is useful for regular
people of course you can Circle things
to search you know I how much I would be
using that but Samsung is making a much
better push into AI than what apple is
doing and now we have to talk about the
cameras the crazy thing is that Samsung
after years of having 10x cameras
actually followed Apple after making fun
of them for having a 5x and put in a 5x
themselves now the other cameras didn't
really change from the s23 ultra uh so
we have that 200 megapixel and some
sometimes there's a little bit of issues
with the photos they still need more
software tuning but the new 5x lens is
incredible in daytime we have better
quality than the iPhone and the latest
pixel they all have 5x cameras um and uh
for nighttime shots we get some great
quality so the low light performance at
night is much better than than it was
before with the 10x so that lens is
great and I love that we can now take
portrait shots with that 5x lens so I
think that was a smart move by Samsung
and the only real complaint that I'll
say about the cameras is that 3x lens
it's an old lens and I don't know why
they still have it in there it made
sense when they had a 10x to have a
three but now the pixel and iPhone
they'll digitally crop into 3x and it
looks better than this dedicated lens so
I think that's really the only bummer
and the only lens that you probably will
not use but what I have to say is that
even after a week when I pick this thing
up and I hold it it feels great the
display is absolutely gorgeous it works
really well and I think honestly guys if
I could have iOS software in the
hardware of the s24 ultra I would gladly
switch over and it's not the software is
bad just iPhone really locks you into
the EC system if you use an Apple Watch
if you use Mac um other Apple
accessories so it is really is kind of
is hard to switch over or almost
impossible unless you're going to miss
out based on other things that you use
that are really helpful um but for those
that are not stuck in that ecosystem
this phone is really really good even
though it seemed like a really boring
minor update it is a great update and a
great user experience compared to the
previous generation so thank you guys
for watching go ahead and click that
Circle above to subscribe check out one
of those videos right over there this
has been Max and I'll see you in the
next one
[Music]
yeah